well i have known many alpha males in my
life
chimpanzee alpha males and i'm going to
talk about
what an alpha male is and because i
think we can
learn a lot from our close relatives
where we have alpha males and as an
example i want to give you
amos a male that i knew who was a young
male and he was alpha male was very
popular
but he got sick and he lost his position
because you know chimpanzee males they
can spot from a mile away if you're weak
and they went for him and he lost his
position and then he got sicker and
sicker
until at some point um we had to isolate
him
the group lived on a grassy island
and we had to isolate him in a cage but
we cracked open the cage so that the
rest of the chimp still had access to
him
and what happened was most touching
other chimps would
bring food to him they would bring wood
wool to him which is the thing that they
used to sleep in
built nests out of and females would put
the wood wool behind his back he was
leaning heavily against the wall and
the way we do his pillows to patients in
a hospital
they were putting that stuff behind his
back and i thought this is the way to go
for an alpha male this
he was loved and respected and everyone
was taking care of him
and this is not always how it goes
because some males don't end so well
when they lose their position
so amis was an example of a male who was
um
liked as a leader and and i think the
term alpha male if you look it up
on the internet you will find all these
business books that tell you how to be
an alpha male and what they mean
is how to beat up others and beat them
over the head and let them know that
your boss and
and don't mess with me and so on and and
basically an alpha male for them is a
bully
and and i really don't like that kind of
description because um
i'm actually partly responsible for the
term alpha male because i wrote this
book chimpanzee politics which was
recommended by newt gingrich to
freshman congressman i don't know what
good it did but
he recommended that book to them and
after that the term alpha male
became very popular um but i think it is
used in a
in a mischaracterization it's used in a
very superficial way
that doesn't relate to what a real alpha
male is and so that's
i'm here to explain what that is the
term itself goes back actually much
further
goes back to the 40s and 50s research on
wolves
and basically the definition is very
simple the highest ranking male is the
alpha male
the highest ranking female is the alpha
female every primate group has one alpha
male one alpha female
not more than that there's only one and
um i will explain how that goes
so first the body language what you see
here is two male chimpanzees who are the
same size
but one is walking upright has his hair
up has a big rock in his hand and he's
the alpha male
the other male is pant grunting to him
is being
submissive to him and bowing for him and
that is the sort of ritual they need to
go through many times a day
in order to have a stable relationship
i'll show you a video from the field
what you will see here is a female pen
grunting to an alpha male
and you will see how that goes the male
is approaching
she grunts at him he has all his hair
up and he displays
i'm actually standing far too close a
chimpanzee
is far stronger than i am and and i i'm
this was not very prudent this
particular video
so uh what you saw him do
is he was he was lifting himself up and
standing on two legs and putting his
arms out that's called the bipedal
swagger
it's a very common posture in
high-ranking males
and it's very recognizable because
humans do this kind of stuff
humans do this all the time and
and what i really like about this
particular picture is the two
old guys to the side this is very
chimpanzee in chimpanzees
we have usually old males who are over
the hill
who cannot be alpha male themselves
anymore
but they start playing games and forming
coalitions and behind the backs of
others
and they become extremely influential
and you may actually have
old males who are more influential than
the alpha male himself
just as an example the three males that
i used to work with most
at the dutch zoo long ago that where i
worked the middle male here
is a 17 year old alpha male the male who
is he grooming on the side
is twice as old and this old male has
made him the leader
so you can imagine that that old male
has an enormous amount of power because
he has made
the alpha male alpha male the male on
the right
is individually the strongest male these
individuals
in captivity you can test that out and
you can know that this male
has no trouble with either one he has
only trouble with the combination of the
two
and so the coalition formation that goes
on in chimpanzee society
makes it much more complex than you
think it means for example
that the smallest male in a group can be
the alpha male you don't need to be the
biggest and strongest male
the smallest male if he has the right
friends and keeps them happy
or he has female support he can be the
alpha theme the alpha male
so so the coalition system makes
everything complex
and i'm always waiting here in the us
for the primaries the end of the
primaries because
that's a moment where you need to
demonstrate unity now let me first show
you how
the unity is shown in chimpanzees what
you see here is two males on the left
who are standing together you also see
the big canine teas that they have
and they're standing together and they
demonstrate to the rest of the group
we are together we are a unit
the males on the right are walking
together in synchrony that's another way
of demonstrating that you are together
and so demonstrating unity is extremely
important in a coalition system
and as i said in the primaries always
i'm waiting for that moment because then
you have two
members of the same party who have been
fighting with each other and they need
to come together at some
some moment and and it leads to very
awkward situations
people who don't like each other need to
embrace each other and stand together
and and that's absolutely essential for
the unity of the party and if you don't
do that the party may fall apart
and so if it doesn't go well like in
this particular case
then the party is in deep doo-doo
because they have not demonstrated unity
so that's a very important part of the
coalition system
and that's something that we share
between humans and chimpanzees
now how do you become an alpha male
first of all you need to be impressive
and intimidating and demonstrate your
vigor on occasion and show that you're
very strong and there's all sorts of
ways of doing that
but other things that you need to do is
you need to be generous so for example
males
who go on a campaign to dethrone the
leader which made them to take two or
three months
where they're testing all the coalitions
in the group they also become extremely
generous
they share food very easily with
everyone or they
start to tickle the babies of the
females they're normally male
chimpanzees not particularly interested
in infants
but when they're campaigning like that
they get very interested in infants and
they tickle them and they
they try to carry favor with the females
so in
in humans of course i'm always intrigued
by these men who
are candidates and hold babies up like
this this is not particularly something
that babies like
but but since it is a signal to the rest
of the world they need to hold them in
the air
and and i was really intrigued by when
we had a female candidate in the last
election
the way she held babies was more like
this which is what babies really like
but she of course didn't need to send a
message that she could hold a baby
without dropping it which was what the
man was doing
so so this is a very common tactic and
male
chimpanzees they spend a lot of time
carrying favor with all sorts of parties
when they are campaigning now what are
the
the privileges and the costs of being an
alpha male
the biggest privilege is females food is
really irrelevant male chimpanzees can
go
a week without food if there's a female
in estrus and they're sexually
interested in her food is secondary to
to sex and so the male chimpanzees they
and and we evolutionary biologists of
course we have an explanation for this
is that
sex leads to reproduction and
reproductive success is the measure of
evolution that's how everything evolves
and so if males can enhance their
reproductive success by being high
ranking
you get automatically the ambition to be
high ranking in the males
so that's the privilege the costs
one cost is of course that you need to
keep your partners happy so if you come
to power with the support of an
old male you need to let that old male
mate with females
if you don't do that that old male is
going to get mad at you and it's going
to you're going to lose him as a partner
so there's a transaction going on if you
become alpha male this way you need to
keep your partners happy
and so that's one of the costs the
second cost is that everyone wants your
position
alpha male position is a very important
position and everyone wants to take it
from you
and so you constantly have to watch your
back you have to be extremely vigilant
for example you have to disrupt the
coalitions of others and that's what
male chimpanzees do quite a bit divide
and roll strategies they have
and so that's a very stressful situation
and we actually have data on this
the data comes from the field from
baboons not chimpanzees in this case
where they did fecal samples on the
baboons and they analyzed them for
glucocorticoids
and what you see here is a graph where
you see that the lower ranking the male
baboon is
the higher is his cortisol level in the
feces
but the alpha male as you see has just
as high a level
as the lowest ranking males and so you
may think that being alpha male is nice
and dandy and is wonderful but it's
actually a very stressful position
and we can demonstrate that
physiologically
now what are the obligations and here
for me
it gets really interesting and it
deviates very much from
your typical image of the alpha male
the alpha male has two sorts of
obligations one is to keep the peace in
the group
we call that the control role to control
fights in the group
and the second is to be the most
empathic the console
in chief basically of the nation so to
speak so first of all
keeping the peace this is a male who
stops a fight between two females
two females on the left and the right
have been screaming and yelling
at each other over food because food is
very important for the females
and so he stops the fight between them
and stands between them like this and
it's very interesting to me
that alpha males when they do this they
become impartial
they don't support their mom or their
best buddy or no no this they
stop fights and they come up for the
underdog in general and
and this makes them extremely popular in
the group because they provide security
for the lowest ranking members of the
group and so they they become impartial
which is an unusual condition for a
chimpanzee to be in because they're
usually very
fond of their friends and so on and
these alpha males who are good at this
they can be very effective at keeping
the peace in the group and the second
thing they do
is they show empathy for others now i do
an enormous amount
of research on empathy and i don't have
time to go into it but empathy is
nowadays a topic that we study in
rodents and dogs and elephants and
primates
all sorts of animals and what you see
here is two bonobos
the the one in front has been beaten up
in a fight the one in the back puts her
arms around her and
consoles her this is also actually how
we measure empathy and young children
by looking at how they respond to
distressed individuals
and high-ranking males they do a lot of
this high-ranking males provide an
enormous amount of comfort
in the group and they go to places where
there are earthquakes or
hurricanes and they provide comfort the
pope does this the presidents do this
all the leaders in the world have to do
this job the queen does it and so on
they all have to do this job so
providing consolation and that's a very
important task
and males who are good at these two
keeping the peace and providing comfort
they become extremely popular leaders
and there's actually some self-interest
involved in it they don't do it just for
the group because it also stabilizes
their position
the more popular a male becomes this
alpha male and the more
the the rest of them respects them and
looks up at to them
the better their position is defended in
case it's going to be challenged by
somebody else because then of course the
whole group is going to
support that male because they want to
keep a leader who is good for them
so the group is usually very supportive
of males who are good leaders and this
is not supportive at all of bullies and
when bullies lose their position and
they may end up
in a very bad situation there this is
data actually on the consolation
behavior this is
data on consolation and chimpanzees and
you see for the
medium and low ranking individuals the
females do more of it than the males
this is basically the whole community
and and this is true for all the mammal
studies on empathy is that females have
more of it than males
but look at the alpha male the alpha
male does far more than anybody else and
so that's the data
on alpha males being the controller in
chief basically
the last thing i want to say is
something about alpha females
mama this is a picture of mama the alpha
female of the arnhem zoo i used to work
who is now all over the internet i think
100 million clicks at the moment
for a video of her dying at the age of
59 which happened last
year and mama was an absolute centrum
of the group so she was not physically
capable of dominating the males
she she ranked below the males but she
was the center of the community and if
there was big trouble in the community
everyone would end up in the arms of
of mama and so she was a very important
figure
and so i don't want to minimize the
position of alpha females in the
chimpanzee group
and then we have a species that is
equally close to us
as the chimpanzee the bonobo we often
forget about the bonobo but the bonobos
have a
matriarchal society and
the alpha individual is a female
generally
generally it's a female who's at the top
of the community and we know much less
about how this is done and how they get
to that position
and what they do it because we know much
less about bonobos in general
but i do want to emphasize that the
alpha in a group doesn't need to
be a male and that actually one of our
close relatives it is a female
so the message i want to leave you with
is that if you
are looking at men in our society
and who are the boss of let's say a
family or a business
or washington or whatever and you call
them alpha male
you should not insult chimpanzees by
using the wrong label
you should not call a bullion alpha male
someone who's big and strong and
intimidates and insults everyone is not
necessarily an alpha male and alpha male
has all sorts of qualities and i have
seen bully alpha males
in chimpanzees they do occur but most of
the ones
that that we have have leadership
capacities and
are integrated in their community and
like amis at the end
they are loved and respected and so it's
a very different situation than you may
think
and i thank you
you